hello welcome to this announcement video  it's a live show one of them monthly  once and this is again on the internet  chess club's side I'll be doing them or  the twitch Ella off the internet chess  club this is a simultaneous display two  ND bots 20 opponents on ya out of ICC  members so if you want to play mean you  have to join the ICC and then you can  play me tonight it will still be  broadcasted on twitch and I will start  on a term in the evening Central Europe  in time which makes it on two in the  afternoon on the US east coast so make  sure to join me will be fun also we can  chat if you are registered on twitch so  it's also good if you just watch and  I'll play yourself so make sure to join  me thanks